we have been encouraged culturally to
criticize people we're in long-term
relationships with not new relationships
new relationships you put the person on
a pedestal you're allowed to just oh
they're wonderful but every Trope out
there and every form of popular media is
like the wife rolling her eyes at the
husband and the husband being like Oh
there's loads some Harpy that castrated
me as if like people are just passive
players in their lives and I I think
that is an incredibly toxic message to
send to people that this is how we
should be relating to our partner like
we should not you don't take the piss
out of your partner in front of people
like the successful relationships I've
seen are where people are just cheering
for their partner where they are
thickest thieves where there is just
this feeling of like man they like each
other like they are they got each
other's back like you wouldn't believe
like man you could take sides against
anybody but take sides against their
partner you're going down like and that
when you see a couple that has that
you just you know they it's that's so
hard to break but but I think that comes
from
having like a
steadfast yeah no I don't do that like I
don't talk my partner yeah like and
you don't talk my partner to me you
know like and that to me is when because
I think we're just so criticized by the
world the world is so full of criticism
we criticize ourselves so harshly that
having a partner who no matter what is
like you've got this I'm With You Like
You okay yeah you screwed up I see
it look I'm not gonna lie to you about
your blind spots you screwed up but you
know what people screw up sometimes you
gotta write the screw up a lot of people
screw up come on get up let's go I know
you have it in you if you have that
person like that I I feel like that's a
that's a superpower to have that effect
on another person yeah one of the things
I love seeing when you look at a couple
and one is talking
uh like in an interview yeah answering a
question especially like intellectual
questions
like uh what do you think about the war
in Ukraine or something and then the
partners talking and the other the other
person is looking at them as if they're
hearing the wisest thing yeah ever like
they're they're looking at them not
waiting for their turn to speak not
thinking about how's the audience going
to take that but they're looking at them
like God damn I'm so lucky yeah to be
with this smart isn't that
but but there's this and they could be
saying the dumbled there's a scene
in the movie True Romance yes because I
love a great movie I mean that Gary
Oldman seems like the greatest scene
ever done in in film you know with
Christian Slater and he but there's a
scene in it where she holds up a sign to
Christian Slater and it says you're so
cool you're so cool and I I like man
like that's it yeah that's it like I
I've always I think I said somewhere in
the book that you know you go to
weddings and like when the bride walks
in you know everybody's looking at the
bride it's her show you know everybody
turns around is the first Glimpse
everybody gets the bride and I never
look at the bride I always look at the
groom looking at the bride
because there's this like to me that's
every like he has this look like this
because this is the first time he's
seeing her in the dress most of the time
and also he's seeing her like holy
she's coming down the aisle we're
getting married like but this is it and
everyone's looking at her
and and I always look at him because I
always think to myself like like the
look on his face is like that's like
this feeling of like holy yeah wow okay
like that's everyone's looking at her
and she's mine and she's coming up here
and we're getting married and I feel
like yeah like that that kind of
adoration
like I think that's the look we're
describing is like adoration like that
the words coming out of their mouth that
they're like yeah that's mine that one's
mine you know that's such a great thing
like it's such a great feeling seeing
the good stuff like with uh with True
Romance I mean you could uh make fun of
the guys totally cringe wearing Elvis
like essentially being a fake Elvis with
Shades and like what what is he doing
it's like watching these kung fu movies
but from her perspective and from any
perspective you could take on him is
this is the the baddest
who's ever lived like he's willing to do
those things for me but not like
it's almost like an epic heroic figure
yeah and we're living in this Epic
hero story and what does that do to him
though yeah that's what see that that's
the point like if there's a point to
this
to this whole thing this whole couple
thing yeah isn't that it yeah like I
don't I don't understand this idea of
you know we had a successful marriage we
were married for 50 something years we
were miserable for 47 of them but we
hung in there like it this is an
endurance event like the primary
relationship of your life you've decided
you're gonna turn into the the like a
50-mile trail race
like why why would you do that like
congratulations you you took the concept
of monogamy and made it something that
two people are absolutely not gonna
enjoy but you hung in there like
congratulations and I understand there's
religious perspectives that say well
it's a sacred Covenant but I I have a
real chicken or the egg problem with
that yeah because I think it was like
well how do we sell this incredibly
stupid concept that isn't working to
people I know we'll tell them God says
you have to and and we'll sign on for
that I I don't buy it I don't buy it
anymore I really because when you see
a successful marriage where you see to
be even without a marriage you see a
pair bond you see a couple that really
love each other and cheer for each other
in that way and like hang on each
other's words that way and like are just
in each other's Corner that way
you see the fake instantly yeah
like you you see the difference right
away it's like if you you know the first
time this is the first time I've come to
Austin I've had I thought I'd eaten a
lot of barbecue in my life
I've never had text this barbecue I
landed I went and had barbecue I was
like okay I've never had barbecue before
apparently this is there's a whole
different thing I think it's the same
thing I think it's like once you see
real love like real love and and I mean
romantic love like real love like that
real Bond real you go oh yeah this other
thing's not gonna do it